ich bin 27 jahre alt und komme aus
bochum auf youtube zeigt tutorials sich
zeigt wie man rezepte nachgekocht rund
um den globus genau so international wie
die rezepte obmann kanal sind so ist es
auch bei mir in der familie meine eltern
zb die kommen aus der türkei
mein papa ist mit elf rübergekommen ein
opa war nämlich gastarbeiter so wie man
es kennt hat ein bisschen geld verdient
und mein papa eben nach deutschland
gebracht und irgendwann hat er dann
meine mama kennengelernt und er hat dann
hals über kopf mit meiner mama zusammen
im café eröffnet und da wurden dann
deutsche torten kuchen angeboten also
nicht wie man es denken vielleicht
jemand türkische oder das ist typisch
deutsche torten die meine mama dann in
der küche selber gebacken hat da habe
ich immer die zeit genossen in der ist
ihr über die schulter gucken konnte dann
damals in der küche des cafés und ich
hab dann ich denke unbewusst von ihr
gelernt um unbewusst auch diese
leidenschaft angenommen und ich habe
dann zu der zeit wo ich dann auch
relativ gut drauf hatte den hamza kinkel
erdmann jetzt sehe man im zusammenhang
mit uhr gemacht und durch ihn kann man
auch so aufträge er hat dann eine
riesengroße familie und da gab es dann
viele baby short partys und dann war ich
immer die torten frau und dadurch kam
ich auch auf das thema youtube das kann
natürlich in dem an den hamburger mir
gesagt du musst den leuten zeigen dass
du kannst und du musst denen das
beibringen damit die genauso button
können wir nun eben auch kochen d'azur
machen ja beides nicht nur banken
sondern auch kochen und ich möchte dass
ich mein online shop den ich sehr stolz
bin auch noch mal erweitert
ich bin hammam sagt komme aus 14 er
unterstütze ich war dann hinter der
kamera
ich finde die entwicklung auch richtig
cool bei uns oder sie haben jetzt mit
einer handykamera aufgenommen wir
angefangen und jetzt aber da sind wir
schon mal der richtigen profi kamera und
das macht richtig viel spaß also was mir
gefällt ist aber dass ihre rezepte
gelegen
vor allem auch das schnitt mir niemand
zenica mittlerweile ermöglichen uns auch
diese partnerschaften
das ginge beispielsweise total auf der
backe und ich kann einfach ich selbst
sein meiner kamera bei mir vom kanal
gibt es nicht nur backrezepte sondern
auch kochrezept also es geht wirklich in
die süße und in die herzhafte schiene
und was ich auch total markt und blogs
da zeige ich dann persönliche einblicke
und das können sie eben nur weil das
interesse der zuschauer da ist und wenn
ihr das nicht verfolgen möchtet dann
abonniert doch gerne jetzt main kanal